[Musik]
seit menschen existieren führen sie
krieg gegeneinander
das wird sich wohl auch in zukunft nicht
ändern aber wie sieht ein krieg im jahre
2050 aus asymmetrisch mit kalaschnikows
und selbstgebastelte bomben im
häuserkampf wurde geführt von
vollautomatischen kampfrobotern und von
ki gesteuerten drohnen wird der
wichtigste krieg vielleicht mit daten
geführt ein cyberwar der auch die zivile
bevölkerung trifft die wichtigste frage
aber bleibt warum werden die menschen
nationen bevölkerungsgruppen
gegeneinander kämpfen und wie kann man
die kriege der zukunft vielleicht heute
noch verhindern
warum führt der mensch überhaupt krieg
sind wir nicht im grunde friedliche
wesen welche grenzen müssen
überschritten werden so dass hass und
aggressionen in gewalt und kriege münden
blickt man zurück dann hat die
faszination am kampf an der jagd und
dann kriegerischer auseinandersetzung
lange tradition
sie ist ein überbleibsel unseres
biologischen und evolutionspsychologe
erbes vielleicht hatten bereits in der
steinzeit aggressive individuellen einen
entscheidenden überlebensvorteil
irgendwann ging es um mehr
die ritter schlachten des mittelalters
wahren gemetzel und einträgliches
geschäft ein ziel dabei war es den
gegner möglichst nicht zu töten
denn ein tod arena war ein wertloser
retter ein gefangener dagegen versprach
ein dickes lösegeld sind wir friedliche
wiesn die mit der aufklärung zur
vernunft kommen ein moderner armeen
schaffen es bis heute jungen menschen
die natürliche tötungshemmung
abzutrainieren regierung und militär
kreieren bedrohungsszenarien und
feindbilder
was folgt sind folter massaker und
gräueltaten
die völlige entmenschlichung bleibt der
weltfrieden auch im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert eine illusion
[Musik]
die ressourcen werden knapp aus dem
globalen web streiten technologie in
rohstoffe und nahrung entstehen immer
wieder konflikte möglicherweise auch
kriege geopolitische gerichte
verschieben sich alte macht
konstellationen sind aus der balance
geraten künftige kriegsszenarien gibt es
viele
sie haben ihrem buch geschrieben die
verknappung des rohstoffs weizen hätte
das potenzial auch krieger auszulösen
warum bei weizen einen
grundnahrungsmitteln es 210 steckt ja
fast überall mit drinnen mittelbar oder
unmittelbar weizen ist das brot das wir
täglich essen
weizen ist tierfutter und ohne
ausreichende weizen versorgung würde es
ganz schnell zu unruhen kommen oder das
ist auch schon passiert
das heißt die anbaumöglichkeiten für
dieses getreide natürlich auch andere
getreide aber für dieses getreide sind
besonders wichtig und da geht es um
flächen da geht es um klimafragen und da
geht es natürlich auch um ökologische
fragen unter welchen bedingungen können
wir für acht neun zehn elf milliarden
menschen ausreichend weizen erzeugen und
das führt dann natürlich möglicherweise
zu geopolitischen verwerfungen in der
zeit wo sowas wie internationale
kooperation und auch internationaler
handel dazu niemand infrage gestellt
werden
heute einen präsident trump sagt so
jedes land für sich
dann möchte ich nicht wissen was das x
bedeutet für handelsströme zum beispiel
wenn es mal klappt wird dann kann man
auch nicht mehr auf internationale
zusammenarbeit setzen
dann wird jedes land zum beispiel
vorräte für sich bunker natürlich ist es
bei weizen wahrscheinlich der erste
rohstoff bei dem man das machen würde
weil da braucht es nur drei vier tage zu
lieferengpässen kommen und ein land ins
chaos
ja es sei denn man geht im weg das recht
des stärkeren zählt und aus dem
handelskrieg wird ein wirklicher krieg
um den walzen also in unserem szenario
im buch das ja nicht der
zukunftsprognose dient sondern der
erweiterung unserer vorstellungskraft
wir sagen nicht so kommt so muss es
kommen oder so wird es kommen das ist
ganz wichtig sein szenario aber in dem
szenario geht es darum dass sich china
durch seine ja sehr progressiv auf eine
investitionsstrategie in afrika dort die
kontrolle über anbauflächen verschafft
hat und die usa dann versuchen mit hilfe
eines letztlich biowaffen angriffs die
chinesische dominanz in afrika zu
brechen
es ist auf jeden fall so dass natürlich
unsere grundnahrungsmittel die uns so
selbstverständlich vorkommen weil wir im
überfluss leben in deutschland und
europa dass unsere grundnahrungsmittel
der gefährlichste auslöser für konflikte
sein können weil wenn da eben engpässe
entstehen dann kommt es zu unruhen das
hat man in nordafrika schon gesehen
vor gar nicht so langer zeit das führt
sehr schnell dazu dass menschen auch
migrieren ganz wichtige frage und es
führt dazu dass möglicherweise ganze
staaten sich in ihrer existenz bedroht
fühlen und dann zu vielleicht auch
militärischen mitteln greifen können
also hier ist agrarpolitik natürlich
wesentliche säule der
geopolitik und auch der friedenspolitik
und das wird viel zu selten gesehen
in einer globalisierten welt hängt alles
mit allem zusammen usa china und diese
drei wirtschaftsblöcke erwirtschaften
seit jahrzehnten mehr als die hälfte der
weltweiten waren und dienstleistungen
jetzt tobt ein handelsstreit der könnte
am ende auch deutsche arbeitnehmer den
job kosten
war freier handel dermaßen kern der usa
seit trump im weißen haus sitzt bröckelt
er
der deal macher hat ein einfaches rezept
america first ganz oben auf trams
abschussliste china strafzölle hat er
schon verhängt aktuell wurde die
telekommunikationsfirma huawei auf eine
schwarze liste gesetzt
die chinesen schießen mit eigenen zellen
auf us agrarprodukte zurück trampel
weiter eskalieren wenn die chinesen
nicht einlenken
er droht mit 25 prozent soll auf alles
made in china das kalkül wer mehr
exportiert hat in einem handelskrieg
mehr zu verlieren
der us-präsident droht auch europa mit
einem handelskrieg trump nimmt bewusst
auch die deutsche autoindustrie ins
visier um zugeständnisse aller europäer
zu erpressen
gewünschter nebeneffekt presse im
europäischen zusammenhalt donald young
hat die weltwirtschaft
durcheinandergebracht der us-präsident
kündigt immer neue zelle anna peking
reagiert jedes mal mit gegenschlägen es
geht um waren und produkte aller art um
rohstoffe aus einem handelskrieg kann
ein echter krieg werden
wir sehen ja gerade in den usa wie
präsident trump die metall frage zur
nationalen sicherheitsfrage erklärt um
seine handelspolitik auch zu
rechtfertigen es geht ja darum in den
usa ein minimum an produktion auch
sicherzustellen
durch diese zölle die ihr einführen will
im bereich aluminium im bereich stahl
auch da sieht man daran dass argument
kam jetzt für viele überraschend vor
allen dingen für die kanadischen
nachbarn aber man sieht daran was für
knallharte fragen da drin stecken ganz
vorgeschoben ist es ja nicht man stelle
sich vor seien völlig arabischer kurs
und aggressiver kurs führt zu konflikten
es kommt zu wirklich militärische
konfrontationen dann aus dieser
zugegebenermaßen ist in perversen sicht
aber ist dann natürlich ist schon
wichtig dass man das aluminium im
eigenen land erzeugen kann und so war
sie würde sagen die amerikaner sind da
gerade einmal kurzfristig am
aggressivsten unterwegs strategisch
gesehen muss man sagen sind aber die
chinesen eindeutig dem sind schlauer
sie haben zum einen die produktion
dieser seltenen erden zwar jetzt stärker
umwelt mäßig reguliert aber doch auf dem
mars dass ihre eigene versorgung damit
sicher stellt sie sind zum anderen in
australien sehr aktiv einem der
rohstoffreichsten ländern der welt darum
gibt es in australien ja auch schon eine
sehr erhitzte debatte darüber ob die
nada nicht einen zu großen einfluss hat
und dann ist china auch wenn man das
immer so als land der ökologischen
katastrophen sieht ideell viel weiter
als die usa die staatsführung spricht
von der notwendigkeit einer ökologischen
zivilisation zu der auch recycling
gehört will sagen
noch mal kurzfristig was das powerplay
anbelangt stehen die usa im vordergrund
aber mittel und langfristig sind die
chinesen eindeutig strategisch lauer
unterwegs also insofern würde ich da auf
jeden fall sagen ist china eindeutig im
vorteil
amerika rüstet auf selbst fahrende
panzer ferngelenkte drohnen und schiffe
autonome waffensysteme die anhand von
algorithmen also vorher festgelegten
regeln mindestens empfehlen
wer im krieg getötet werden soll und wer
nicht im pentagon hier hinter mir wird
sogar noch weiter gedacht eine abteilung
des verteidigungsministeriums erforscht
die manipulation des erbguts in pflanzen
und insekten denn die könnten mit den
veränderungen auch als waffen eingesetzt
werden natürlich angeblich nur von den
feinden amerikas um hier ernten zu
vernichten oder die bevölkerung
anzugreifen
aber so weit sind wir noch nicht
zunächst einmal setzen die usa ihre
wirtschaftskraft und ihren
technologischen vorsprung ein
denn auch mit handelskriegen und
cyberattacken kann man länder in die
knie zwingen
dabei sieht die us-regierung china als
künftigen hauptgegner nicht russland
donald trump lässt neue nukleare
mittelstreckenraketen entwickeln um sie
in asien zu stationieren und er steigt
aus internationalen verträgen aus um
freie bahn für ein neues wettrüsten zu
haben also wer denkt dass es in zukunft
weniger kriege geben wird der täuscht
sich gewaltig ein ferngesteuerter der
krieg selbständiger die waffensysteme
desto weniger eigene verluste und desto
niedriger die schwelle solche kriege
auch zu führen
mit diesen raketen des typs dürfen
übersetzt ostwind hat china militärisch
stark aufgerüstet die dunkeln gibt es
mittlerweile mit unterschiedlichen
reichweiten mit konventionellen
sprengköpfen oder als interkontinentale
atomwaffe sie starten von land von
mobilen raketenwagen oder mittlerweile
auch von boten sie sind so etwas wie das
ass im ärmel des chinesischen militärs
und sie sind sinnbild für pekings
militärstrategie
denn die kommunistische führung chinas
blickt zuallererst vor die eigene küste
dort im pazifik hat china einen riesigen
sicherheitsgürtel aufgebaut aus der luft
abgesichert durch die ostwind raketen
und chinas wachsende luftwaffe unten im
südchinesischen meer ist die marine im
einsatz und auch atomwaffen bestücktes u
boote in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
waren die usa im pazifik militärisch
weit im vorteil
jetzt haben die chinesen und drei chinas
staats und parteichef hu ping die
gewichte verschoben
laut einschätzung des amerikanischen
pentagon kann im krisenfall kein
us-flugzeug trägerverband mehr
ungefährdet durch den pazifik steuern
das schränkt die bewegungsfreiheit der
amerikaner deutlich ein und zeigt welche
bedeutende rolle china heute als
militärmacht spielt nach den usa steckt
kein staat der welt mehr geld in
rüstungsausgaben
china ist dabei zwar mit großem abstand
die nummer zwei in der rüstungs welt und
anders als die usa hat chinas
volksbefreiungsarmee kaum
kriegserfahrung aber die führung in
peking lässt keinen zweifel daran dass
chinas militärische fähigkeit auch
künftig mit aller kraft ausgebaut werden
soll
iranische atom meiler britische
krankenhäuser der deutsche bundestag mit
jedem hacker-angriff wächst auch das
geschäft mit der sicherheit warum israel
startups in der cyber security branche
vorne mitmischen und zwar ganz vorne
liegt auch an einer militäreinheit der
einheit 8200 gut abgeschirmt in einem
unscheinbaren gebäude auf dieser base
hinter mir
dort arbeiten elitesoldaten cyber
soldaten
diese elitesoldaten lesen mit höheren ab
e mails telefone sie hätten sich in die
computer ihrer feinde und vereiteln
cyberattacken
tausende sind in dieser einheit
beschäftigt sie ist ähnlich strukturiert
wie die us-amerikanische nsa und auch
fast so groß sicherheit wird seit jeher
in diesem kleinen land groß geschrieben
denn kriegerische auseinandersetzungen
und terror sind seit staatsgründung hier
an der tagesordnung
israel wehrt sich mit einer
schlagkräftigen und gut ausgebildeten
armee dass israel auch marktführer in
sachen cybersicherheit ist liegt daran
dass der staat bereits vor 30 jahren den
cyberspace als vierter verteidigungs
raum definiert hat nirgendwo sonst auf
der welt sind militär wissenschaft und
wirtschaft so gut vernetzt wie hier
schon in der schule sieht das
verteidigungsministerium geeignete
kandidaten aus und lockt sie in
programmier- kurse später haben diese
dann gute chancen in der wirtschaft oder
in der wissenschaft und so manch einer
hat auch ein erfolgreiches privates
cyber security unternehmen gegründet
solche start ups werden hier zuhauf
gegründet nämlich rund 300 pro jahr und
der israelische staat hilft mit
finanzspritzen
diese firmen entwickeln dann cyber
abwehr systeme aber auch autonome und
automatische kriegsmaschinerie wie
kürzlich ein projekt mit einem
unbemannten panzer denn in israel
bereitet man sich auf alle szenarien vor
den krieg im cyberspace mit möglichen
terroranschlägen auf die infrastruktur
genauso wie auf den realen krieg in dem
in zukunft autonome und automatische
waffen eingesetzt werden und israel
cyberkrieg
sind bekannt dafür alles möglich zu
machen
auf bahnhof oder flughafen kraftwerk
oder krankenhaus ein angriff auf unsere
infrastruktur kann erhebliche schäden
verursachen
es fließt kein strom der verkehr wird
lahmgelegt menschenleben sind bedroht es
ist jedoch sehr schwer sich gegen cyber
attacken zu schützen ist angriff die
beste verteidigung
was passiert wenn ein krankenhaus opfer
einer hacker attacke wird wenn
lebenswichtige rechner plötzlich nicht
mehr funktionieren
unser aller infrastruktur ist schlecht
geschützt wenn kraftwerke gehackt werden
der strom länger ausfällt oder züge
fehlgeleitet werden das verkehrsnetz
zusammenbricht
hacker-angriffe können uns sehr
empfindlich treffen
das ist keine utopie das ist schon
passiert
mai 2017 mit dem virus bonner cry
treffen hacker die anzeigesysteme der
deutschen bahn und legen britische mode
aufnahmen lahm die patienten nicht mehr
behandeln können
nun setzt der innenminister auf eine
hoch umstrittene idee umschalten von
abwehr auf angriff
eine neue stufe im cyberwar krieg im
netz mit eben solchen mitteln bekämpfen
wenn ihr es stattfindet dann werden sie
zuerst die frage stellen warum habt ihr
euch dafür nicht vorbereitet ihr habt es
doch diskutiert schutz allein das reicht
horst seehofer nicht schon jetzt spät
der bundesnachrichtendienst fremde
server aus künftig aber so der plan
sollen die agenten sich nicht mehr nur
um schauen sondern selbst angreifen
virtuell zurückschießen sozusagen zum
beispiel indem sie von hackern erbeutete
daten auf fremden servern löschen oder
selbst schad-software einschleusen und
ganze server im ausland einfach
zerstören
es wäre ein tabubruch der digitale
gegenangriff durch den bnd der hack beck
und es ist keine neue idee
günter heiß war bis 2018 im kanzleramt
für die geheimdienste zuständig endlich
sagt er
passiert etwas offiziell wurde das nicht
diskutiert und wir haben uns im
gegenteil immer damit beschäftigt was
brauchen wir eigentlich für einen
juristischen überbaus da kann man also
wirklich jahre und jahrzehnte in vielen
arbeitsgruppen darüber diskutieren das
bringt aber gar nichts wenn wir einen
worst case haben wenn wir zusammen
brechen ökonomische oder soziale systeme
haben und wirklich etwas machen müssen
etwas machen klingt gut praktisch aber
unmöglich sagen experten und fragen wen
sollen staatliche hacker den treffen bei
einem zeitkritischen vorfall wie in den
hacker-angriff auf eigene netzwerke kann
man in der regel nicht sofort wissen wer
der verursacher des angriffs ist man
weiß dass in der regel nach einer
gewissen zeit und bei vielen cyber
vorfällen wissen wie es auch heute noch
nicht profi angreifer nämlich tarnen
ihre spuren im netz kapern ganze ketten
von fremden rechnern
doch erwischt man schnell das falsche
ziel warnt die opposition stellt sich
den fall vor dass der angreifer etwa
einen rechner einen server in einem
krankenhaus kapert und von diesem
rechner aus seinen angriff auf seine
deutschen bundestag startet dann würden
wir als gegenangriff ist gekaperten
rechner in ein krankenhaus in frankreich
zerstören und dort alle daten löschen
ich glaube fest daran dass die beste
verteidigung die verteidigung ist und
nicht der angriff
deswegen muss es immer darum gehen die
vorbeugung und die verteidigung zur
priorität nummer 1 zu machen wenn hacker
angreifen sollen regierungs hacker dann
irgendwie gegen irgendwen zurückschlagen
mögliche schäden müsse man halt in kauf
nehmen meint horst seehofer im juni will
er seinen plan im bundessicherheitsrat
vorlegen dem geheimen gremium für
deutsche sicherheitspolitik
die zahl der hackerangriffe hat sich in
den letzten jahren eigentlich immer
stetig erhöht was glauben sie wie wird
das noch in zukunft weitergehen
wir werden sowohl von der quantität ja
eine deutliche weitere zunahme haben von
hackern dürften auch qualitativ wird es
deutlich professioneller werden das
liegt daran dass wir sehen dass der
angreifer sich professionalisiert früher
waren das so die script kiddies die ganz
einfachen dem keller mal gezeigt haben
was sie können heute sind das hoch
organisierte hoch professionelle gruppen
die jahren greifen wenn es also so
weitergeht und von der ganzen welt aus
hacker angriffe gestartet werden können
es gibt also immer leute die sich neue
trojaner viren et cetera ausdenken und
die anderen die eine firewall bauen
müssen kommen wir unserem wettrüsten
eigentlich im cyberraum nicht drum rum
wir haben natürlich ein wettrüsten wenn
man das so bezeichnen möchte das ist der
normale wettkampf hase und igel es geht
das dann ist es darum wer ist der
schnellere digitalen bereich kann man
sehr schnell sehr viel geld verdienen
indem man ganz neue tolle produkte
weiterentwickelt genauso digitalisiert
sich natürlich auch die organisierte
kriminalität organisieren sich alle
möglichen anderen formen der angreifer
weil man damit effektiver und
effizienter handeln
und dieses vertrauen das bild auf dauer
bestehen jetzt weiß man ja nie so 100pro
wer war's denn eigentlich der da gehackt
hat wer hat einen angegriffen wie
schwierig ist das wenn man zum beispiel
sieht vor den eu-wahlen hat man damit
gerechnet dass es hacker angriffe geben
könnte dass es menschen geben könnte die
irgendwie einfluss nehmen wollen auf die
wahlen ist nichts passiert aber wenn mal
etwas passieren würde ob in eu fall oder
nato wie reagiert man eigentlich mein
untereinander abgestimmt wie man gegen
schlagen will
im bereich der reaktion ist man sehr gut
mit danach gestand wir haben eine
vielzahl von austauschen mit anderen
sicherheitsbehörden beispielsweise mit
aus ihren frankreich aber auch mit
demenz esc in england oder auch
entsprechend in den usa oder unseren
anderen engen partnern wie in holland
österreich und so weiter
hier tauschen wir uns auf der einen
seite was sind die trend der angreifer
was die andere sektoren die dort aber
wie reagiert dennoch darauf und denken
sie daran das thema vonne cramon katja
das waren der große erpressungs wällen
die wir gehabt haben im bereich wenn es
um mehr
und da haben wir auch unmittelbar mit
england frankreich spanien mit allen
möglichen anderen nationen auch
telefoniert um zu hören wie sieht es bei
euch aus was tut ihr wie ist der stand
und was hilft auch gerade geht diese
anderes stellen
das funktioniert sehr gut und hängen und
wie schwierig ist dann eigentlich das
zusammenarbeiten bei so einem virus wie
simone qual erwähnte er die
infrastruktur direkt angreift der also
das totale chaos auslösen kann
wie kann ich mir das konkret vorstellen
wie man dann zusammen sozusagen sich auf
die spur begibt zunächst einmal geht es
darum zu festzustellen wären davon
betroffen in deutschland haben wir
seitdem die sicherheitsgesetze 2015
verabschiedet worden an der meldepflicht
für die kritischen infrastrukturen also
für die großen logistikunternehmen für
die finanzdienstleistung
telekommunikation energie usw
das wird soll jetzt mal weiter ausgebaut
werden daraus bekommen wir eine vielzahl
von meldungen die dann im lagezentrum
zusammenfließen und wo man dann eine
gemeinsame bewertung durchführen
aber feststellt man hat eine besondere
lage dann wird das übergeben das
sogenannte cyber abwehrzentrum das
dauert wohl die ganzen anderen behörden
institutionen des bundes zusammen
arbeiten also beispielsweise bundesamt
für verfassungsschutz
bundesnachrichtendienst bundeswehr
bundespolizei bundeskriminalamt bsi und
so weiter und dann führen wir abgestimmt
auch ein austausch herbei mit anderen
ländern und organisationen wie ist der
sachstand und was tut ihr dort gegen
schickt heraus beispielsweise ein
sogenanntes mobile in zu dem schluss bon
steam an wird diese mobilen des teams
gehen raus und bringen den patienten das
opfer in eine stabile seitenlage
gleichzeitig übernehmen natürlich auch
die kollegen des bundeskriminalamts von
straff vermittlungen und den täter zu
fassen
und da gibt es natürlich sehr groß
abfolge denken sie das thema politics
was wir anfangen diesen jahres gehabt
haben oder denken sie an den großen eine
andere waffe die telekom router haben
wir ein botnetzwerk da ja auch innerhalb
weniger monate aufgeklärt worden
jetzt haben sie eben auch schon bei der
frage nach der zusammenarbeit viele
behörden aufgezählt die es in
deutschland gibt aber auch dieses
international gibt wo man dann
miteinander zusammenarbeiten muss jetzt
soll es ja auch noch eine cyber agentur
geben die auch noch mal spezielle
befugnisse haben wir da nicht eigentlich
irgendwann behördendschungel oder sind
sie nur froh dass es noch mehr menschen
gibt die sich dieses themas annehmen
jeder hat ja seine eigenen teilbereiche
wofür zuständig ist
das bsi als cyber sicherheitsbehörde der
bundesregierung des bundes ist zuständig
für den schutz der bundesregierung der
bundesverwaltung dieses zur verteidigung
aber auch für den schutz der kritischen
infrastrukturen
wenn dann andere stattgefunden hat dann
schützen wir erstmal die systeme
gleichzeitig übernimmt dann aber das
bundeskriminalamt die ermittlung des
täters das heißt sie brauchen auch
fähigkeiten
das haben wir zum beispiel gerade
gesprochen über das thema der neuen
agentur die gegründet worden dass dort
geht es darum dass wir über disruptive
technologie nachdenken also neue
technologien die man zukünftig in fünf
jahren zehn jahren einsatz bringen kann
die dann quantensprünge der
sicherheitsverbesserungen realisieren
ermöglichen im bereich der
informationssicherheit und dort arbeitet
man sehr eng und vertrauensvoll zusammen
und stimmt sich auch ab dass dort die
arbeitspakete sind da man wie zum
beispiel auch ein einen mitarbeiter
entsendet im aufbaustab um dann diese
agentur also auch entsprechend auch in
unserem sinne voranzutreiben
sie sind die dritte große revolution der
kriegsführung nach der erfindung von
schießpulver und atomwaffen
sie erkennen ihr ziel und zerstören ist
sie entscheiden über leben und tod so
genannte killer roboter handeln
selbstständig menschen sind an der
entscheidung zu angriffen nicht mehr
beteiligt künstliche intelligenz macht
es möglich aber sind diese kampfdrohnen
technisch ausgereift treffen sie
wirklich in jeder noch so komplexen
kriegssituation die richtige
entscheidung
so könnte der krieg der zukunft aussehen
soldaten seite an seite im einsatz mit
einem unbemannten bewaffneten panzer zu
werden killer roboter genannt agieren zu
lande im wasser und in der luft sie
kennen keinen hunger und keine angst
gehorchen bedingungslos noch werden
autonome waffen wie zb kampfdrohnen von
menschen gesteuert
doch in zukunft könnten
vollautomatisierte waffen gar ins
schwärmen über leben und tod entscheiden
ohne menschliche kontrolle nur mit
künstlicher intelligenz
[Musik]
momentan handelt es sich noch um
lernende maschinen sie sind sehr
unzuverlässig
es gibt keine garantie dass sie das tun
was du willst sie können fehler machen
diese computer können leicht abstürzen
und gehackt werden
auf internationalen messen messen wie
der index in abu dhabi wird deutlich das
wettrüsten um unbemannte waffen ist voll
im gange
ganz vorne mit dabei china südkorea
israel russland und die usa
unsere mission unser ziel ist
situationen sicherer zu machen gefahren
zu eliminieren um unsere soldaten und
seeleute vor schaden zu schützen
der mensch muss die kontrolle behalten
so minister mars gerade erst warnte er
vor der unkontrollierten ausbreitung von
autonomer kriegs technologien wir
brauchen regeln für autonome
waffensysteme killer roboter die auf
basis anonymer datensätze und völlig
jenseits menschlicher kontrolle über
leben und tod entscheiden sind bereits
heute eine erschreckend reale
perspektive nur lippenbekenntnisse
kritisiert thomas küchenmeister von der
kampagne zum verbot von kilometern einem
zusammenschluss von hundert
nichtregierungsorganisationen aus 54
ländern
er fordert von der bundesregierung eine
verbindliche ächtung dieser waffen
deutschland ist ja eigentlich das
einzige land was sozusagen vertragt euch
eine ächtung zugesagt hat in form
nämlich der koalitionsverträge das ist
bislang de facto nicht passiert
deutschland spricht sich aus für eine
unverbindliche politische erklärung will
damit das problem der autonomen waffen
lösen das greift viel zu kurz 28 länder
haben sich bereits für ein verbot
ausgesprochen sollte sich deutschland
dem anschließen wäre das ein starkes
politisches signal gegen die verbreitung
von tötungs robotern in der zukunft wie
also wird unsere welt in zukunft
aussehen wie leben die arbeiten die das
essen und das trinken wir viele fragen
wir werden weiter versuchen sie zu
beantworten auf unserem weg in die
zukunft
er ist 20 47 würde ich sagen da war ich
nämlich dass luft komplett waren
[Musik]